بسيناريو مجنون ميسي يقود التانجو للقبن
مونديال ثالث بابي يدخلوا تاريخ المونديال
من بوابات تويتر وحفل ختامي كاس العالم
غناء عربي
في السماء هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم
من العربيه رياضه
التي اقيمت بينهما على استاذ
دخل اكل مهاجم منتخب فرنسا اليوم تاريخ
تويتر خلال نهائي مونديال قطر لاعب فريق
سان جيرمان الفرنسي خطف الانظار بتسجيله
الثنائيه خلال اقل من دقيقتين ليصبح اول
لاعبا يسجل الثنائيه في النهائي منذ عام
2002 هدفه الثاني تسبب في كتابه اكثر من
24 الف تغريده خلال ثانيه واحده بحسب الى
مصر مالك تويتر
انظروا الملايين من عشاق كره القدم حول
العالم تابعت ايضا الحفل الختامي للعرس
المونديالي والذي لم يستغرق اكثر من 15
دقيقه وشهد الحفل عروضا مرئيه وغنائيه
استخدمه خلالها المنظمون التقنيات بصريه
شكلت مجسمات واقعيه لدلافين وحيتان في
ارجاء الملعب بدات وكانها تحلق في استاد
لوسيل في منظر بصري مبهر
تفاعل رئيس الفرنسي المتواجد في المدرجات
مع الهدف الاول الذي سجلهمبي جذبت جذب بعد
اسات الكاميرات ماكرون وردود افعاله ايضا
حظيات باهتماما اعلاميا كبير الى جانبه
ميسي وزوجته واطفالي الذين
في نهائي مونديال قطر
[موسيقى]
ونبقى مع ميسي حيث تداول رواد السوشيال
ميديا اليوم الفيديو الكرتوني الخاص
باللاعب الارجنتيني حيث نشرت الصفحه
الرسميه لبطوله كاس العالم 2022 والتابعه
للاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
انجازاته رفقه المنتخب الارجنتيني في ورقه
وظهر في الفيديو ايضا الكلب الشهير الذي
يتواجد في منزل ميسي وبجواره زجاجه عليها
صوره زوجه